i'll bet that you thought that you'd
seen the last of me in that first evil
saddler video in which i went off on all
sorts of things especially about reading
primary text which you shouldn't do you
can watch that video to find out why
it's thanksgiving
and
the cracks open up and i can jump out
and talk at you tell you the things that
other guy
isn't going to lay out for you for
example thanksgiving such a sham think
of me
sort of like the grinch
here to ruin
thanksgiving for you and if you're not
an american and don't know what
thanksgiving is
i might still be able to ruin it for you
anyways so
i've got a lot to say we'll see how much
time i get
first however as people do in youtube
videos i should do the obligatory
sorts of things telling you to subscribe
to
comment to like don't do any of those
things that's all
nonsense that not only benefits that guy
not me and that leads into the topic
gratitude thanksgiving what is
thanksgiving all about well it's about
giving thanks
and
we can go into all the
narratives and mythologies about
pilgrims and native americans and who's
actually responsible for it but that's
all [ __ ] anyway you don't want to
hear about that
what you want to hear about is gratitude
and why you shouldn't be showing any of
it or talking about it especially that
stupid game that people go around the
table each of us should say something
that we're thankful for the next time
they ask you to do that you say i'm
thankful that i'm not going to say
anything sort of like when people are
asked about what they're going to give
up for rent and they say i'm giving up
giving up something gold medal always go
meta is the way that makes you look
sophisticated and ironic and you don't
have to commit to it either you could
say you were just doing a joke after you
tick everybody else at the table off or
irritate them they're already probably
stressed out enough from traveling and
having to be with people that they don't
spend all that much time with and worry
this time about politics and what they
can say and what they can't say and code
words and things like that so you just
go ahead
and add to that and then sit back and
watch the fireworks go off
or if you've got a well-adjusted family
you might have to poke a bit more right
hook poke hit them find things
everybody's got some limits some
breaking points and it doesn't matter
you don't have to be the kid at home
from college who's naturally going to be
in the ass
be that old crazy aunt or uncle or
whatever equivalent you want to be
who disrupts everything and says the
inappropriate things
or you can always
criticize the food that's being served
you can say well this is not the way
that grandma made it or you could say
this isn't the way we get it from target
or uh pick and save or whatever other
local grocer you happen to have
or you could say oh there's too much
oh there's not enough spiciness you can
always find something to be
ungrateful about you see it's important
for thanksgiving that you not only don't
talk about gratitude you don't get into
all this silly stuff about
i'm so thankful
you need to display the opposite that is
in gratitude that way you are balancing
out the scales right everybody else like
sap or
is pulling down this way you put some
weight on the other side
at least until they kick you out
what is gratitude well you know it's
something that you feel and something
that you display
in relation to somebody else giving you
a good turn doing what the agents call
a
benefit
one way to get out of that is to
tell yourself that those things that
people are doing they're not as good
or they're not exactly what you want or
it's at the wrong time they're doing it
in the wrong way
that way you've got nothing you have to
be grateful for as a matter of fact you
can think about your entire life i mean
some people would say you should be
grateful for the very fact that you
happen to be alive at all
or that you know you're born in this
wonderful time when we can communicate
with each other in so many ways over the
internet but anything that you've got
like that there's a way to flip it
upside down
and look at it pessimistically
pessimistically is what they call it of
course you call it not being a sucker
being realistic
just holding the mirror up to society as
they used to say back in the day so
i'm not pretending that this is some
sort of coherence
go-to plan with a checklist or anything
like that i'm just giving you a few
ideas about how you could take
thanksgiving and turn it upside down
turn a smile
into a frown take gratitude and turn it
into
its opposite time for me to go hopefully
that has given you enough to think about
for
this thanksgiving and i'll see you
sometime down the line
you